dr. Malo he loves at this film he loves
that he's now you yet now here's the oh
yeah look at that looks like all the
time
he is so completely happy all the things
that he suffered and it's funny he sent
me a link eight there was a Nigerian
comedian that was talking about my
performance in the movie and he said he
said Will Smith he's doing a Nigerian
accent in his film and the haters will
say that it is no good but I think that
is not true I think he sounds like a
Nigerian with a concussion
for actors you know you all have to do
accents but Ryan we don't think of
Canadians as having accents and yet you
we do
you've lost your accent you would say
yeah I sort of trained myself out of it
but you know I go back home and it pops
up again it's that's all I hear that's
all Ottawa oh yeah this audible I can
hear em about it's a up wild cat it's a
boat that's not saleable say it the way
you say you talk about are you having a
boat but it's all my everything is I
it's a bad word but I'm sorry so you
handle everything without fuck-buddy and
is it something about the Canadian
accent that makes you a really bad liar
um yeah whilst that yeah we're not we're
not good at lying or fighting really
that's been slappy not very sexy where'd
you go to the border trying oh yeah yeah
I was I where my wife is a foodie she
loves these apple pies that they make at
this at this place in Vancouver where I
grew up so we grabbed a bunch of them
and headed we're driving back down to
the States and we're across the body not
a little cross the border with wasn't
illegal right yes and this guy knew
something was going on and we get up to
the border crossing high Sheen avenues
Yap I suppose almost like Hollywood
actors salmon like a kilo of cocaine
you know
but he knew sound was going on deprive
yeah yeah haribol haribol like the worst
poker basement where spy facing and yeah
and he says uh with my voice always gets
really high when I'm when I'm like lying
because like he got anything any fruit
any vegetables in that cuddles like and
he's basically a agent had the other
hooky he looks at me goes hey I remember
that you're a movie did that movie just
friends and I was like yeah yeah yeah it
was like you're that song at the end of
it were you saying this I swear by all
for one and it's like yeah he's like
yeah go ahead sing dance monkey I'll bet
you dance
by the next stop that's when CT showed
you famous eat for us you know you've
whales skills around October after mask
of zorro they thought it was Spanish
yeah yeah I've got the red part carpet
and they go no it's bad I go hola that
is like gracias gracias
you saying anything about me as a
gracias
stood stand alone Will Smith Ryan
Reynolds Catherine zeta-jones me there
is no us
and then it's we you know I'm a member
of the Academy yes